le dr karl weiss est avec nous bonsoir
dr weiss alors maisonneuve rosemont
beaucoup de gens sont inquiets éclosion
multiples dans ce centre hospitalier qui
était un centre qui devait recevoir la
colite donc d'une certaine façon c'est
normal mais quand pensez-vous parce qu'à
l'hôpital général juif chez vous ou
ailleurs on semble mieux équipé pour
faire face à ce genre de défi
écoutez le problème majeur c'est pas les
gens c'est souvent les infrastructures
les infrastructures sont souvent
vieilles à maisonneuve heureusement
saint vital que j'ai bien connue j'ai
travaillé maison nord pendant de
nombreuses années donc j'ai travaillé
avec des gens qui dans les spécialités
chirurgicales et médicales étaient
extrêmement compétents les gens en
urgence aussi et le problème c'est
souvent des problèmes quand vous avez pu
voir ce soit sacré coeur que ce soit à
maisonneuve que ce soit maintenant un
santa cabrini ou ailleurs où on est
chaud c'est souvent des hôpitaux qui
sont désuets d'un point de vue
structurel d'un point de vue
construction c'est les hôpitaux faut pas
oublier qu'ils ont été construits dans
des années 40 50 et en étant 2020
donc on fait de médecine du 21e siècle
dans un environnement qui est du 20e
siècle
l'autre chose aussi c'est l'importance
évidemment d'essayer de bien garder des
équipes qui sont clés de les préserver
pour pas introduire donc dû covic 19 à
l'intérieur des établissements de soins
aigus
on l'a vu dans d'autres pays c'est ce
qui a été fait dans d'autres pays où on
a essayé de confiner des équipes
particulière pour cali faire passer d'un
environnement à l'autre où on nous
aurait pu être en contact avec la coved
19 puis s'infecter à ce moment-là et
ramener ça quand des chevaux de troie
à l'intérieur d'une institution mais est
ce que vous croyez que le
le réseau va tenir que les réseaux
montréalais des hôpitaux va tenir que
parce que les urgences ou s'ils
commencent à déborder comment quelle est
votre lecture des choses
donc la première chose au québec les
urgences débordent depuis très longtemps
ce n'est pas une nouveauté
les urgences vont déborder là on a eu
une période exceptionnelle ne quasiment
irréel de voir d urgence quasiment vie
où on a tout fait en pratique donc là
ils vont revenir avec quelque chose de
normal et les gens sont là pour les
urgences donc il faut que les gens qui
ont besoin d'aller à l'urgence
n'hésitent pas à y aller parce que ça
c'est un autre problème
la deuxième chose c'est que le système
de santé un piège réussi à maîtriser la
première vague jusqu'à un certain point
parce qu on était préparés parce que
jusqu'à un certain poids il ya des
choses qu'on qui ont été plus beaucoup
plus difficile surtout au niveau des
équipements de protection personnelle
mais une fois que on a réussi à passer
je vous dirais le choc de la première
vague
là on se retrouve avec un choc qui vient
des chsct et à ce moment là probablement
que pour la prochaine période
le système devrait tenir le problème
c'est qu'il ya des goulots
d'étranglement actuellement il n'y a pas
de capacité des patients qui sont dans
des centres
je vous dirais aiguë pour aller
facilement vers des centres de
réhabilitation c'est à dire l'un des
patients dans tous les hôpitaux le mien
comme ceux d'ailleurs qu'en maison
heures comme sacrée et amar tou qui sont
co vie positifs qui ont plus vraiment
besoin d'être à l'hôpital puis on veut
pas les retourner dans un ch sld et on
sait pas trop où on veut aller retour
on est donc lié à la maison alors ces
gens là ont besoin d'une structure comme
l'hôtel dieu où ça a été créé et il
faudrait probablement plusieurs où on
puisse les envoyer pour essayer de vider
leurs tables de gens qui sont pas très
mal mais assez malade c'est très
important ce que vous expliquer ce qu
ici explique comme vous dites le goulot
d'étranglement il ya trop nord et les
centres ne les veulent plus ces gens là
alors non ils sont un peu dans un no
man's land l'on sait plus où les mettre
alors ça au québec on est souvent
habitué à ce genre de choses là dans les
hôpitaux on est souvent d'ailleurs par
des urgences décor et puis là ça dépasse
un peu la ville 19 c'est souvent parce
qu'aider clos des tremblements c'est à
dire on a des patients souvent qu'ils
ont fini des soins dans les
réguler en a plus besoin de garder ces
gens là dans des soirées du mais on
n'est pas capable d envoyer dans la
ressource suivant qui serait capable d
accepter ainsi de vider l'hôpital de ces
patients là pour que le flot des
patients d'urgence continuent de
circuler alors souvent c'est le problème
de ces goulots d'étranglement et du fait
aussi il faut pas oublier qu'il ya des
hôpitaux à marianne dont mais en inde
ont fait des efforts considérables pour
accepter beaucoup de patients donc on a
vu que le maisonneuve sacré-coeur
l'hôpital général juif ont été des
hôpitaux qui ont accepté des grosses des
grosses quantités de patients dans koh
vite on fait dans des efforts
considérables et qui maintenant ben
c'est sûr avec les goulots
d'étranglement se retrouvera à gérer des
situations plus difficiles en plus de la
vétusté d'aider nos maux et en plus
aussi fait que les patients covit faut
pas l'oublier sont des patients qui ont
tendance des fois dans certains cas des
raisons comme d'oxygénation et c'est bon
mais voilà on va suivre ça j'ai quatre
questions pour vous ce soir du public
docteur je suis une grand maman de plus
de 60 ans qui vit un beat generation
avec mes trois petits enfants tous aux
primaires quelles seraient vos
recommandations face au prochain retour
en classe écoutez d'abord il faut savoir
si la manière en question est en santé
ou pas parce que si elle a 60 ans elle
est en pleine santé
son risque est relativement faible ou
plus faibles et puis évidemment c'est de
s'assurer que les enfants lorsqu'ils
rentrent à la maison on se lève les
mains qui peut-être qu'il va falloir
aussi je sais pas quel âge on les
petits-enfants
mais est ce que le port du masque est
une chose qui serait envisageable chez
ces enfants
évidemment les très très jeune c'est
difficile mais quand ils sont plus
grands là on va dire huit ans etc
c'est peut-être plus facile donc il ya
du gros bon sens mais il faut pas non
plus paniquer à l'idée vous savez de
retourner à l'école parce que durant la
saison par exemple d' influence un la
grippe ordinaire les gens envoient leurs
enfants à l'école qui on le sait ou à la
garderie ce qui est encore pire
on sait que c'est une zone où il ya
beaucoup de grip hier et on peut
attraper la grippe et ramener la grippe
à la maison et la grippe l'infini rosa
pour les personnes plus âgées et pas
forcément un extraordinaire oui un
vaccin mais c'est pas un vaccin qui est
super efficace des x 40 45 %
ayant des cas donc oui il faut pas non
plus penser que le risque zéro le risque
n'hésitez pas héros non plus durant
l'école normale ordinaire quand c'est la
saison de l'influenza on ajoute un
risque et mais faut être comme vous
dites agir avec grobon simple davantage
de mesures de 2,2 des consignes de
lavage de mains etc
quels sont les responsables on y revient
quels sont les risques pour un parent
enseignant qui doit retourner en classe
de transmettre le virus à sa fille de
cinq ans qui souffrent d'asthme sévère à
écouter c'est possible tout est possible
et évidemment mais hélas on pourra
trouver toutes les situations et des
circonstances possibles
je vous dirais que c'est de minimiser
les risques
les risques seront jamais 0
malheureusement oui il peut y avoir des
enfants qui vont tomber malade c'est pas
c'est pas impossible mais c'est pour ça
qu'il va falloir mettre des mesures en
place et s'ajuster en fonction des
mesures ici ça marche pas il faut être
capable de dire on revient en arrière
donc elle ne pas être là qu'est ce qu'on
va faire
il faut que les écoles distribuer des
masques par exemple à tous les
enseignants
il faudrait que les enseignants que les
enfants et des jeunes alcoolisés pour se
laver les mains fréquemment il faudrait
qu'on s'assure qu'ils se lavent les
mains fréquemment il faut aussi
s'assurer que si vous avez un enfant qui
est malade
vous ne l'envoyez pas à l'école je pense
que c'est important ça aussi il faut pas
que les gens se disent ah ben tiens il
ya un petit rhume aujourd'hui tout ça un
peu et c'est un peu de fièvre mais il
est pas si pire ça va à l'école pour ce
soit tout le monde qu'ils mettent
l'épaule à la roue et qui met un peu de
2-2 gros bon sens à l'intérieur de ça
deux dernières questions docteur va être
parlez-nous des orteils coved
apparemment ça circule beaucoup auraient
fui de 14 à des orteils bleus depuis un
mois après vérification la clinique de
dépistage ils ont confirmé en voir de
plus en plus alors ça c'est quelque
chose qui a été vu surtout chez les plus
jeunes on n'en voit pas tant que ça moi
je n'ai pas de pédiatrie mais mes
collègues pédiatres ont décrit 5 le plus
fréquemment et à son enfant ou pas
surtout céder des espèces de portet qui
deviennent bleuté ce qu'on sait de plus
en plus
avec la colique 19 c'est que c'est un
virus qui est qu'on appelle athérogène
c'est à dire qu'il a tendance à
provoquer des caillots dans le sang
et puis il ya des gens par exemple le
plus âgé qui font des embolies
pulmonaires
on a vu vous avez des jeunes adultes
chez qui c'est qui on a décrit des
accidents vasculaires cérébraux et là on
décrit chez des enfants ou des
adolescents
des problèmes qui sont des orteils
bleuté probablement dû à des petits
problèmes de vaisseau qui vont être
bloqués par par des caillots et c'est la
caractéristique d'interroger ni citer de
la cofidis n'a c'est à dire c'est le
virus qui provoque ces petit caillou qui
vont dans bloquer la circulation et qui
vont fort qu'elles ont créé encore très
bien connu mais ces hypothèses une
dernière de clara six ans je ne me
sépare jamais de mon toutou préféré je
la porte avec moi partout où je vais
mais lui il ne peut pas se laver les
mains est ce qu'il pourrait avoir le
virus sur lui et me transmettre il
faudrait faudrait que le tout reste en
confirmant aussi le tour est en
confirmant le problème est ce qui peut
bien les objets inanimés peuvent à
l'occasion où il servir de vecteur mais
c'est plutôt rare et il faudrait que ce
soit une contamination soit grossière
mais si on reste en confinement y
compris pour le tout aux ide vrai
problème merci docteur 20 et ça très
bien tous merci beaucoup au revoir bonne
soirée